après les affrontements à Sainte Soline
dans le département voisin des
Deux-Sèvres les antibacines demande la
fin des chantiers en cours chez nous
aucun projet de ce genre la vingtaine de
réserves d'eau qui se trouve en
Indre-et-Loire et modeste mais le débat
entre agriculteurs et écologiste est
toujours vif comme a pu le constater
elle est à Turquie
une grande étendue d'eau réservée aux
agriculteurs pourtant ça n'est pas une
bassine mais plutôt une retenue
colinaire quelle différence ici le
bassin est formé à l'aide d'un barrage
et alimenter uniquement par le
ruissellement de l'eau le long de la
vallée cette retenue donc permet aux
agriculteurs de mieux appréhender les
périodes de sécheresse
on a quelque chose de plus régulier pour
l'alimentation des années de sèches
comme cette année où il y a eu très peu
d'herbes dans l'année si on n'avait pas
eu cette sécurité ça aurait été la
panique malgré la retenue malgré tout ça
on a quand même acheté du maïs un peu de
maïs à l'extérieur pour assurer le
l'alimentation des animaux cet hiver une
étendue de trois hectares pour trois
exploitations agricoles différentes soit
plus de 60 000 m3 stockés ici de cette
manière les retenues colinaires sont
tolérables pour la ces pentes
l'association de préservation des
milieux naturels de Touraine vont poser
des problèmes si elle compte comment
c'est se multiplie si elle
s'agrandissent s'ils seront devient on a
de véritables lacs comme il y a dans les
Deux-Sèvres l'eau doit être quelque
chose qui doit être partagé partagé de
façon raisonnable entre l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques ou non en
Indre-et-Loire il n'y a donc pas une
seule bassine et pour le moment aucun
projet de la construction